museums house all sorts of interesting
specimens in their collection you might
think of an unusual bird or a remarkable
mammal but would you think of a rusty
car visit science educator and video
blogger Emily Grassley who's earned
widespread acclaim for her efforts to
inspire public interest in the Natural
Sciences Grassley's YouTube channel the
brain scoop scoop has almost half a
million subscribers meg Oliver paid her
a visit
Meg good morning good morning Emily
graslie is part comedian part science
tutor Forbes named her as one of the 30
under 30 standouts in the field of
education and her videos have been
viewed more than 24 million times ready
to dump some stink water Emily graslie
comes alive talking about dead things
she stars in her own youtube channel at
the brain scoop her warm and witty
delivery turns the most unappealing
topics into entertaining science lessons
the 29 year old also holds one of the
coolest job titles as chief curiosity
correspondent at the Chicago Field
Museum are there any other chief
curiosity correspondents at museums
across the country not that I know of
museum president Richard lariviere
remembers spotting Emily for the first
time well it was astonishing a young
woman whom I'd never heard of just
happened to blog that she was visiting a
field Museum and fan
took their kids out of school and a
hundred of them came in here to see her
and you decided to hire her on the spot
on the spot and you accepted the job on
the spot oh absolutely I was it said
whatever you want
many of these devil babies are made from
guitar fish her job is to highlight the
museum's scientific research on her show
you could say this legacy still has way
she's done it all from digging up fish
fossils like their to dissecting animals
like skunks this smells so bad and
zebras you really love dead things yeah
they can teach you so much her unusual
journey started in 2013 Grassley was an
art major at the University of Montana
when she visited the zoological museum
on campus I mean completely overwhelmed
with specimens all over from the floor
to the ceiling like taxidermy birds
flying around the room from an artists
perspective it was a really magical
place you loved it so much you started
volunteering there yeah immediately and
then you started a blog yeah
that blog about cleaning bighorn sheep
and stuffing and skinning roadkill
caught the attention of Hank green one
of the most popular creators on YouTube
he helped her start her own channel
thanks for giving me my own show on
YouTube I'd never done it before never
done videos don't have a background in
science and really didn't have any
outside input from anybody who had
worked in a museum
other than the curator at the time but
we're winging it we were totally winging
it 100% winging it it's the biggest dog
it worked
right off the bat they did a five-part
series on this word killed Wolfe yes
that that was one of the greatest
moments I think in brain scoop history
where we were on our way driving to Fish
& Wildlife to pick up this 90 pound wolf
that was in their deep freezer and James
was like you should call Liz and make
sure that she knows we're on the way the
hub sorry
I felt like old LensCrafters
she has managed to win over the
scientific community with a degree of
enthusiasm that I haven't seen in my 40
some-odd years in academia but the
response hasn't always been positive
with close to half a million subscribers
she's battled a barrage of negative
comments online you have a piggy nose
too you look kind of fat or things like
maybe you would have more viewers if you
dressed sexier this was your version of
me to kind of it was it really was and I
wanted to talk about it the more I
thought about and she did devoting an
entire episode to it titled where my
ladies at I would have to say would be
the frustratingly negative and sexist
comments that I have to sift through in
my various inboxes on a daily basis the
media took notice she wanted to call out
the haters and show the next generation
of curious students it's okay
to put yourself out there from that
point onward I saw a real shift in my
community I saw them holding themselves
accountable for what they were saying
there was like low tolerance for those
sorts of comments going forward it kind
of smells like if you had like leather
shoes some consider grassley a feminist
science icon but she just wants to
inspire the next generation lifelong
learning is really important to what it
is that we do and it's important to me
as a person right and that's what I want
people to walk away with it's just a
desire in a self motivation to ask
questions of the world around them you
see a breath of fresh air oh my gosh I
don't know if I love dead things but I
love her yes yes outstanding I mean just
upstanding I googled her her videos and
one word decomposition but she is
fearless talk about it after she first
did it first specimen she ever prepared
she thought there was something
seriously wrong with her no she just
knows it's curiosity all right my golfer
thank you